das geschäft mit hundewelpen boomt in
corona zeiten
die leute kaufen die hunde das ist
unfassbar
die meisten welpen werden online anonym
und illegal verkauft gegen horrende
preise
man muss einfach wissen dass illegaler
tierhandel das lukrativste geschäft für
die verkäufer nach drogen- und
waffenhandel ist ein insider der
jahrelang illegal welpen verkauft hat
packt aus ich habe meinen tag 4 ab 1000
euro gemacht was für geile kohle
ich bin ehrlich das war so die
leidtragenden sind tiere die oft im
ausland unter erbärmlichen zuständen
leben
sie leben in ihren exkrementen und
kommen nie aus ihrem keller herren
beschlagnahmte hunde werden in tierheim
aufgepäppelt doch die tierhändler
fordern ihre kostbare ware mit allen
mitteln zurück torten wird teilweise
wirklich schon angst um unser leben auch
hier als ware vor allem für den
deutschen markt gerade mal ein paar
wochen alt ist dieser kleine malteser
welpe
weggerissen von seiner mutter um in
deutschland mit ihm ein geschäft zu
machen
gerettet von melisa wie kam es dazu sie
entdeckt bei ebay kleinanzeigen eine
verdächtige annonce mein bauchgefühl hat
auch dann gesagt das stimmt etwas nicht
der sagen wir nicht so gesund aus für
mich sehr komisch in duisburg verabredet
sich mit der tierschutzorganisation vier
pfoten und einer tierärztin melissas
verdacht hinter der annonce steckt einer
der zahlreichen illegalen welpen händler
sie machen sich das große interesse an
jungen hunden zu nutze zurzeit wohnt der
welpe handel mehr als zuvor jetzt mit
corona und lockt die leute kaufen die
hunde das ist unfassbar die uns wenn
auch unglaubliche summen dafür gezahlt
in absprache mit der
tierschutzorganisation hat melissa in
einem chat kontakt mit dem verkäufer
aufgenommen
kommt er aus deutschland ja wie alt ist
der denn haben sie das muttertier zu
hause nein
sieben wochen und dann geben sie den
schon ab ich muss ich habe probleme mit
dem haus in dem ich wohne und ich habe
ein neugeborenes melissa und die
tierschützer wollen den welpen händler
auf frischer tat ertappen
melissa hat sich mit dem händler
verabredet die tierschützer begleiten
sie geben sich als ihre mutter und tante
aus sie drehen mit versteckter kamera
fahren zu einem vereinbarten treffpunkt
die polizei ist informiert und vor ort
950 euro soll der malteser welpe kosten
der händler taucht auf haben sie auch
noch ein mädchen
ich muss meine cousine in rumänien
anrufen kommen die aus rumänien
wer also kann man auch noch andere
rassen haben ein yorkshire terrier
ich rufe meine tante anna und sie sagt
mir bescheid und bezahlt den transporter
kein problem
der anbieter hatte gelogen die welpen
kommen also nicht aus deutschland
sondern aus dem ausland die polizei
nimmt den händler in gewahrsam
das hauptproblem ist dass die welpen
viel zu früh von den muttertieren
weggenommen werden weite strecken
transportiert werden unzureichend
geimpft sind keinen immunschutz haben
und dadurch sehr oft lebensbedrohlich
erkranken auch daran sterben
sina hanke arbeitet in hamburg im
zweitgrößten deutschen tierheim in den
corona zeiten kommen mindestens einmal
pro woche
tiere aus polizeilichen
beschlagnahmungen hier an früher war das
die ausnahme
diese malteser welpen haben überlebt
viele andere schaffen das nicht
die welpen kommen in einem ganz
erbärmlichen zustand in der regel zu uns
zum einen sind sehr viel zu jung und
viel zu klein
das an sich ist ja nicht gleich ein
krankheitsbild aber es bringt eben
häufig mit dass die erkrankungen wie
beispielsweise parvovirose mitbringen
das heißt sie haben weswegen blutigen
durchfall das ganze darm system löst
sich im grunde auf das ist ein
wahnsinnig qualvoller und schmerzhafter
tod man muss sich wirklich vorstellen
dass ganz banal gesagt vorn und hinten
blut aus dem mund heraus kommt diese
welpen starben schon nach wenigen tagen
im tierheim wenn sie zu krank zum
verkauf sind werfen die illegalen
händler sie weg so wie dieses tier
es lag in einer mülltonne und verendete
noch auf dem weg ins tierheim
im vergangenen jahr haben die
tierschützer in einem besonders großen
fall eng mit der polizei zusammen
gearbeitet
wir sprechen hier von dem ganzen
familien clan der sich so organisiert
hat dass es wirklich fahrer gibt dass es
lagerstätten gibt das ist
produktionsstätten natürlich sowieso
dass es schwer gibt das heißt bevor
solche verkäufe stattfinden wird erstmal
ein heer aus leuten losgeschickt und
gecheckt ob das wirklich ein guter
verkauf wird ob die käufer echte käufer
sind oder wird hier schützer womöglich
da vor ort auftauchen
das zeigt eben wie man fürs das ist was
für strukturen das sind dass das hoch
kriminell ist was da passiert der
mutmaßliche chef der bande ein 33
jähriger deutscher wurde im vergangenen
jahr festgenommen er sitzt nun in
untersuchungshaft dringender tatverdacht
tierquälerei und betrug lena hanke
vermutet sein geschäft läuft längst
weiter
man muss einfach wissen dass illegalen
tierhandel das lukrativste geschäft für
die verkäufer nach drogen- und
waffenhandel ist wir reden beim
illegalen welpenhandel von richtig
produktionsstätten im ausland meist in
polen und ähnlichen regionen wo wirklich
fabrik ähnlich welten produziert werden
für den deutschen markt für die
nachfrage hier eine kleinstadt in polen
ende januar polizisten und tierschützer
sind zusammen im einsatz
sie haben einen tipp bekommen hier soll
eine sogenannte kunde fabrik seien eine
qualzucht so fassen sie mich bitte nicht
an
wollt ihr meine hündin ihr diese wollte
die weiterverkaufen
der hundebesitzer ist aggressiv greift
die tierschützer an will verhindern dass
die tiere untersucht werden die hunde
für die zucht sind draußen im schnee
angekettet andere harren in der kälte in
zwingern aus sogar welpen
viele tiere sind verhaltensgestört
beißen sich gegenseitig fast tot
[Musik]
es gibt immer mehr hunde fabriken wie
tierschützer gregor gysi nennt er hat
den zugriff mit der kamera gedreht 18
von 100 hunden waren ausgehungert
beinahe tot
solche hunde retten wir jeden tag das
ist eine typische pseudo zuchten polen
diese runde sollten einen polen aber
auch im ausland verkauft werden
nach dem zugriff begreife ich erst was
wirklich passiert ist und ich muss
meinen sogar für jemand mit starken
nerven ist es unerträglich
tierschützer dokumentierten schon zu
zeiten vor corona das elend der hunde
rund 2.000 tiere hat er allein im
vergangenen jahr gerettet doch mit
corona wurden die zustände schlimmer
diese hunde leben in ihren eigenen
exkrementen seit drei bis vier jahren
sehen sie nie das tageslicht weil sie
nur im keller geraten werden vor allem
bleiben die hündinnen die pausenlos
gewähren müssen
die meisten welpen aus illegalem handel
werden übers internet verkauft kalkar
hätte niemals vermutet dass ihr hund
cookie aus einer hunde fabrik stammen
könnte auf ebay hatte sie eine annonce
von einem zwergspitz jo awer entdeckt
das tier sei geimpft die eltern vor ort
zu besichtigen
die anzeige hat für mich ganz normal
gewirkt der preis war mittel bis hoch
würde ich sagen und da stand auch dann
noch drin dass er sie auf jeden fall
auch in liebevolle hände kommen so in
die tiere deswegen hatte das auf mich
ganz positiv gewirkt die händlerin
übergibt ihr das tier mit impfausweis
auf der straße schon auf dem rückweg
wird der hund krank bekommt blutigen
durchfall zu hause sieht die erfahrene
hundebesitzerin dass der impfausweis
eine fälschung ist cookie überlebt knapp
rach erstattet anzeige wegen betrugs für
kunden ist kaum zu erkennen ob es sich
um einen legalen oder illegalen züchter
handelt diese verkäufer machen sich
vieles zunutze einmal corona da ist es
immer leicht gesagt nee da können wir
leider nicht in meine wohnung bitte den
verkauf vor dem hohen haus stattfinden
lassen
deswegen erscheint das den potenziellen
käufern nicht merkwürdig man bekommt ein
impf dokument mit ziemlicher sicherheit
aber nicht das passende zu dem welpen
wir haben in hamburg sogar mittlerweile
den fall dass welpen benutzt werden von
diesem verkäufer nur zum impfen das
heißt es gibt tatsächlich einen welpen
der wird zurzeit ihr ärzten geschickt
und dort geimpft und jeweils einen
impfausweis für dieses tier ausgestellt
das tier wird sicherlich auch irgendwann
daran versterben weil es eine
überdosierung schlichtweg bekommen hat
und dann wird irgendeine impfpass mit
einem welten der überhaupt nicht
dazugehört verkauft
er weiß wie die illegalen händler die
kunden austricksen wir treffen andreas k
seinen richtigen namen nennt er nicht
vor zehn jahren stieg er in das geschäft
mit illegalen welpen aus polen ein
angefangen haben muss man sagen aber
wegen des geldes weil man muss darüber
legen ich habe damals die chance
bekommen aber mal aus polen 10 labradore
zu bekommen für pro stück preist 150
euro und das war freitag wo die gekommen
sind aus polen und am samstag waren sie
alle verkauft ich stand da ich habe 6000
euro eingenommen
das heißt ich habe meinen tag 400.000
euro gemacht was für geile kohle
ich bin ehrlich das war so als fahrer
eines transporters mit polnischen
hundewelpen ist er viele male
unbehelligt über die deutsche grenze
gekommen was mit kontrollierter
natürlich dann wird er angehalten die
fahrer und wird gefragt muss ein wogegen
die hunde hin und sagte pfarrer belgien
oder holland und schon sind wir in
diesem transit und die polizei die lässt
also wie will man das kontrollieren ja
das ist immer eine glückssache
der bayerische grenzübergang walserberg
immer wieder findet die bundespolizei
bei kontrollen illegale welpen in den
fahrzeugen die meisten kommen aus
osteuropa
allein die bundespolizeiinspektion
freilassing hat in den vergangenen drei
monaten acht verbotene werden sonst
wurde gestoppt und dabei rund drei
sekunden sichergestellt bzw in ein
tierheim gebracht
in engen boxen fast verdurstet und
verhungert werden sie von der
bundespolizei zufällig aufgegriffen
die beamten informieren die zuständigen
veterinärämter und die hunde werden dann
meist ins nächste tierheim gebracht
im tierheim passau werden sie
aufgepäppelt entwurmt geimpft
falls die illegalen händler die kosten
erstatten müssen die welpen ihnen wieder
zurückgegeben werden so sieht das die
deutsche rechtsprechung vor
mehrfach musste ich schon hundewelpen
wieder aushändigen die wir je mühevoll
aufgepäppelt haben und es bricht einem
das herz es bricht einem wirklich das
herz und wenn man es immer und immer
wieder machen muss und es ändert sich
nichts und gesetzlich und die leute
kaufen weiter und es werden keine
strafen eingeführt keine richtigen das
lässt einen verzweifeln und resignieren
auch irgendwann abgelegen im wald liegt
ihr tierheim
dadurch kam es schon häufiger zu
gefährlichen situationen besonders
aggressive händler forderten von ihr die
herausgabe beschlagnahmter welpen auch
ohne zu bezahlen
es war auch schon so dass wir ein
sicherheitsdienst hier hatten weil wir
anrufe bekommen wirklich aggressive
anrufe aus rumänien bulgarien serbien
und die fordern auch vehement ihre ware
man muss es so sagen ein und dort wird
teilweise wirklich schon angst um unser
leben auch die leute die wirklich in den
richtig illegalen welt man verstrickt
sind also wirklich kriminell kriminell
sind die haben es dann auch oft noch mit
ganz anderen dingen zu tun also auch
gerade wenn man nach osteuropa geht dass
das sind dann auch frühere drogendealer
oder immer noch gebogen dealer das dann
manchmal prostitution dabei also das ist
dann nicht nur welpenhandel sondern
welpenhandel ist ganz oft ein teil des
ganzen
andreas k konnte all das nicht mehr mit
seinem gewissen vereinbaren er stieg
nach einigen jahren aus dem geschäft aus
für ihn gibt es seither nur eine lösung
und das grausame geschäft zu stoppen
wenn die regierung aber verbieten wurde
zum beispiel tiere online zu verkaufen
wenn man nur das vermieten würde dann
haben sie schon 90 prozent des illegalen
handels vernichtet wir fragen nach bei
der bundeslandwirtschaftsministerin den
welpen handel im internet gänzlich
verbieten will sie nicht auf den
internet-plattformen dort wo gewerbliche
gewerbetreibende sicher anmelden müssen
wenn sie zum beispiel tiere anbieten
sie kann man nach verfolgen aber
privatanbieter kann man nicht
nachverfolgen und viele tarnen sich als
privatanbieter deshalb hat ist für
angebracht und für notwendig dass wenn
tiere angeboten werden dann auch
nachverfolgbar sein muss mit adress und
mit allen angaben wer der anbieter ist
schärfere gesetzliche regelungen für den
tierhandel im internet hat die
ministerin bislang nicht vorgelegt sagen
kritiker dabei sollte deutschland
vorreiter sein wenn deutschland ein
regel macht haben wir auch die chance
entsprechend eine regel im gesamten eu
raum zu haben und das wäre schon eine
größe und ein schlag gegen diesen
illegalen welpenhandel schon seit jahren
geht das so hunde werden in fabriken
erzeugt und wie ware behandelt ein
geschäft mit dem tierleid auch für den
deutschen markt
[Musik]